This idea of slope doesn't
just work with hills and
staircases it works with
mathematical graphs as well.
Lines have a slope,
just like hills and stairs do.
Take this line, for example.
If I pick any two points in this line,
let's say this one,
which is 0,0, and I don't know,
this one which occurs at 2,4.
I can compute the rise
over the run of this line.
So the rise would be this
vertical increase in distance.
And the run would be
the horizontal increase over here.
And I can tell goes up one,
two, three, four.
And it goes over 1, 2.
4 and 2.
So the slope of this line is
equal to the rise over the run,
which in this case is 4 over 2 or
just 2.
Now let's calculate the slope of this
line, thinking slightly differently, and
let's see what happens.
Instead of using 0, 0 and 2,
4 let's use 0, 0 and a different point.
Let's use 0,0 and I don't know 3,6.
Well now the rise is six and
the run is three.
If I calculate the slope as the rise
over the run, I still get a value of 2.
So it doesn't matter
which points you choose.
A line slope Is a line slope.
So let's practice with
a slightly different line.
Let's look at this line.
So what is the slope of this line?
You can enter the answer
here as rise over run, but
make sure it's fully simplified.